et france télévisions au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le journaliste
animateur samuel etienne et son équipe
de france 3 ont tourné ce lundi
notamment avec jérémy rencurel un espoir
du bmx une séquence de sur les terres à
des champions une émission de 52 minutes
pour découvrir les athlètes français
sélectionnés pour les jo de rio elle
sera diffusé fin juillet sur la chaîne
publique
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
il était temps au micro de michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas d'andré et
l'idée c'est d'abord de comprendre les
difficultés du sport alors là je l'ait
compris très très concrètement toutes
ces bosses
et puis de faire comprendre aux
téléspectateurs ce qu'est vraiment un
champion moi j'adore le sport le sport a
pris ces dernières années ces quinze
dernières années énormément d'importance
dans ma vie la course à pied d'abord
l'endurance de manière générale j'ai
découvert le triathlon il ya deux ans je
fais beaucoup de sport mais comme un
amateur et ç'a pris une part importante
de mule dans ma vie parce que ça
m'apporte énormément humainement ça me
change les idées d'abord on est dans les
métiers parfois un peu stressant et puis
ça me donne de l'endurance tout ça me
permet de tenir le coup un peu plus
longtemps en plateau par exemple